valérie pécresse est en pleine forme
elle est très belle bâtisse dans cette
campagne elle et ragaillardi par son
débat avec eric zemmour elle regrette
d'ailleurs madame le pen que finalement
vous vous soyez dérober du débat qui
avait été envisagé entre elle et vous
peut-être que vous avez eu peur je ne
sais pas bien sûr c'est assez mon stylo
après avoir vu ba c'est beau c'est
possible ça c'est bon c'est le moi j'ai
eu l'impression qu'après que valérie
pécresse et miss qu'il faut bien appeler
une rouste à eric zemmour vous vous êtes
peut-être dit que vous vouliez refusé se
répandent monsieur consignes et j'ai
demandé un débat crèche depuis deux mois
depuis le mois de janvier
elle ne voulait pas d'abord elle a voulu
attendre d'être sûr que j'ai mes
parrainages bon très bien donc nous
avons attendu jusqu'au bas de mars et
puis au moment où nous devions débattre
elle a décidé de débattre avec eric
zemmour alors je vais vous dire vous
avez été très réjoui par ce débat je les
trouvais moi pitoyable pour la politique
est l'un et l'autre aucun à gagner je
sais c'était vraiment une hormone de
croissance de l'abstention des gens qui
regardaient ça se sont dit mon dieu si
la politique c'est ça et bien
probablement une partie on dit je n'irai
pas voter donc je veux dire - c'est ce
débat là qui m'a convaincu de ne
débarque ni avec l'un ni avec l'autre
parce que j'ai trouvé le niveau minal en
a marre
merci
mon avis vous avez vous avez au
contraire constaté moi j'ai trouvé ce
débat très utile parce qu'il a montré
les limites d'eric zemmour et il a
montré qu eric zemmour était quelqu'un
qui font faro n'es quelqu'un qui
pensaient toujours être plus intelligent
et plus à voir plus de choses que les
autres et en fait il s'est fait plier
dès les premières minutes la femme qu'on
va dépoter hammerson a plié perçage et
vassy et et à mon avis c'est ça que
c'est ça qui vous fait peur valérie
pécresse elle la veut débattre avec
marine bien sûr ma mère
elle voulait faire un parent en fait tu
me fais rire exil ou après maintenant
mais elle elle et elle est maître de son
temps elle quand elle le faisait
consignes alors là ce que vous avez
battrai avec elle avant la fin de
l'année avant la fin de la campagne
avant le premier tour ses consignes et
non à voir l'image où ils ont donné donc
vous y êtes vous faites comme emmanuel
mais on ne lit pas dans l'écouté excusez
moi les hurlements les tumaco pied non
c'est toi qui dit m'a copié non c'était
c'était mes programmes et non mais
sérieusement estimé sens je suis désolé
de vous dire que moi je suis dans l'état
d'esprit aujourd'hui
de non seulement d'être second tour mais
de gagner cette élection présidentielle
mais moi le combat dans un dans un bain
de boue machin très peu pour moi voilà
près d'accord alors mais en tout cas
elle a répondu oui charlie non mais
simplement je pense que personne n'est
personne n'est dupe de ça je pense que
vous êtes non mais pardon même je veux
pas être désagréable ce soir mais je
vais désagréable je pense que je pense
que vous êtes conscient de cela pensée
consciente madame vous êtes consciente
de vos propres limites vous savez que
finalement vous n'êtes pas une noire
manches 1 vous n'êtes pas beaucoup plu
ou des pas contents
alors et vous savez que vous ne feriez
pas mieux qu eric zemmour c'est pour ça
que vous vous êtes dérobés c'est comme
ça et vous fait vous serez vous serez
vous faites comme macro qui veut pas
débattre et vous gérez votre avance
finalement vous gérez votre avance dans
les sondages comme une rentière com com
mais oui je suis désolé de le dire un
peu comme ce que vous êtes dans la vie
ça déteint sur votre manière de faire de
la politique mais oui pardon vous gérez
votre avance dans les sondages vous avez
peur de la confrontation et du débat
donc ça n'est pas qu emma rime pas avec
le fait de répéter ce
parler parce que je pense que cette
morgue mais n'y a pas de mépris mais n'y
a pas d'art objectivement 6 6 0 c'est
quelque chose c'est de refuser le débat
voyez j'ai réussi quelque chose dont les
français ne veulent plus donc si
l'équipe de valérie pécresse c'est la
continuation si vous voulez de cinq ans
des manuels macron qui lui même a été
très arrogant très méprisant et bien ça
va détourner les gens en fait de cette
candidature je crois que vous lui rendez
pas service en ayant ce comportement là
mais fortement jamais j'ai dit que vous
refusez
je vous le dis très gentiment m mais
quand même je vous le dis je pense que
vous rendez pas service à votre candidat
et vous pensez-vous madame que les
français ils sont content de vous voir
vous présenter pour la troisième fois
après que votre père s'est présenté lui
quatre fois à l'élection présidentielle
ça fait donc cette fois qu'on a un le
pen à l'élection présidentielle vous
pensez que c'est respecter les français
de vivre de cette rente de l'élection
présidentielle et de la politique et
vous pensez que c'est les respecter
aussi de vous maintenir dans une course
dont vous savez très bien qu'à la fin la
fin elle est écrite avance ou le sait
vous avez dit vous même si vous avez dit
vous même tout à l'heure que les
sondages les uns à la suite des autres
finissait par dire une vérité vous
servait d'outil à emmanuel macron je
veux pas utiliser de termes désagréable
et une expression bien connue qui est
celle d' idiots utiles vous servait
d'outil emmanuel macron pour se faire
réélire et vous savez très bien qu'il a
tout fait depuis le début pour être
contre vous au second tour parce qu'ils
les cieux mais oui la théorie du complot
n'est pas une théorie du complot
accélère tout non il fait tout
[Applaudissements]
alain richard
savez très bien que vous êtes en fait
son allié objectif dans cette campagne
puisque vous êtes son sauf-conduit vous
êtes son assurance d'être réélu haut à
l'élection présidentielle mais monsieur
consignes pardon mais tous les sondages
indiquent que votre candidat te ferait
moins bien commun on parle non mais que
tout le monde serait moins bien que moi
où j'ai mes jours donc je veux dire un
mot vous voulez vous parler au nom des
français
si les français étaient agacés et bien
il ne me mettrais pas au second tour je
pense que j'y serai ils ont toujours
refusé de vous élire ça fait sept fois
qu'un le pen se présente à l'élection
présidentielle le refus a été
systématique vous n'avez jamais été élu
donc s'il avait voulu vous mais pensez
vous de l'arrivée quand il l'aurait fait
vous savez quoi vous faites partie des
enfants gâtés de la plume à ces moelleux
voguer pensée attendait même le faire
c'est moi l'enfant gâté oui moi il m'a
offert à partie sur un plateau mais
monsieur consigne et moi je roule avec
une voiture avec chauffeur s'est depuis
ma jeunesse non mais pardon excusez moi
c'est moi l'enfant gâté de la police à
langer ou dire monsieur consigny d'abord
nationales c'est quoi excusez moi vous
pouvez arrêter vous êtes les rires ce
n'est pas un parti créé par votre père
et vous pouvez me dire que je suis
encore jeune la pole je me suis présenté
marine le pen je me suis présenté à la
tête du front national
j'avais d'ailleurs quelqu'un contre moi
et croyez-moi
difficile oui la bataille a été assez
difficile
et d'ailleurs je les gagner pas
largement je l' ai gagnée à 60 et
quelques pour cent voyez donc oui
c'était quand même relativement
difficile
la démocratie des vins sur internet en
avant ben oui va-t-elle être élu mais il
y avait
des sondages tous les jours pour se
demander si ça allait arriver ou pas non
mais écoutez madame mais c'est qui ce
soit dans votre position dans la
politique sioniste j'ai été à la tête de
ce mouvement réélu quatre fois et je
crois que ceux qui m'ont élu ont eu
raison puisque je suis arrivé au second
tour de l'élection présidentielle et que
je m'apprête à y être à nouveau oui j'ai
quand même
dernière fois ça prouve quand même que
j'ai réussi à démontrer que j'étais
capable de rassembler un très grand
nombre de français je suis allé au temps
oui d'accord mais je consigne bien sûr
ça a l'air facile pour vous mais non
vous voulez vous c'est vous présentiez
très certainement et joseph à ça je dis
que c'est que ça fait des années que je
le pose la question de l'intérêt me bats
pour eux je me bats pour eux je me bats
parce que je pense que je serai la plus
solide et la plus courageuse pour porter
des mesures qui sont des mesures qu'ils
appellent devenir 'juste valeur' mention
dans un sens la démocratie on
n'arrivait pas que de réprimer jeudi le
capturer stocker les questions pour le
chat est ce que vous pensez y est
naturelle et non est-ce que poursuit
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
personnel chaque consigne est ce que
vous pensez aujourd'hui que valérie
pécresse peut battre emmanuel macron oui
bien sûr moi je pense tout simplement je
vais y venir oui mais écoutez vous venez
avec votre public qui rigole à vos
blagues c'est bien non c'est très bien
se dit rien mais aussi je vais ramener
de dire voyez moi je suis pas si je vais
amener des figurants mais arrêtez avec
ça arrêtez je suppose que c'est madame
harel dit que c'était votre truc vous
essayer de rassurer c'est une stratégie
de dédiabolisation les chats le karaoké
le machin on a bien compris moi il se
trouve que je me laisse pas amadouer
contrairement à ceux qui sont passés
avant moi et je comprends que ce soit
désagréable pour vous l'enjeu est
important mais oui et je pense pour
répondre à la question de cyril oui que
valérie pécresse a beaucoup plus de
chances que vous de battre emmanuel
macron et c'est pour ça qu'il a mené
cette entreprise de démolition contre
elle parce que elle elle a un programme
qui est solide parce que elle elle a pas
dit tout et son contraire j'ai regardé
un certain nombre de vos déclarations
entre les entre le l'élection actuelle
et les élections précédentes vous dites
sur tous les sujets systématiquement
tout et son contraire on avait parlé de
commencer ce débat sur la réforme des
retraites vous avez complètement changer
de braquet sur la réforme des retraites
vous vouliez la retraite à 60 ans pour
tous s'étaient chiffrées des dizaines de
milliards d'euros vous avez changé de
braquet parce que vous vous rendez
compte qu'en fait c'est pas crédible
vous nous avez bassiner pendant des
années avec cette histoire de sortir de
l'eau o à laquelle à mon avis vous même
vous ne comprenez rien vous en étiez
même à nous parler de lait qu on allait
arriver à l'écu enfin c'était une usine
à gaz pas possible évidemment vous avez
abandonnés çà mais on peut quand même
avoir une angoisse puisque vos porte
parole disent que ça reste un horizon de
2 de sortir de l'euro tout à l'heure
vous avez parlé avec yannick jadot des
énergies renouvelables et du nucléaire
il ya quelques années les énergies
renouvelables vous étiez à fond pour
maintenant vous nous dites qu'il faut
oui maintenant vous nous dites qu'il
faut couper les subventions et en 2012
étiez contre le nucléaire vous disais
qu'il fallait sortir oui qu'il fallait
sortir du nucléaire et maintenant vous
êtes pour le nucléaire donc vous dit en
fait tout et son contraire sur poutine
on passe les détails mais vous êtes
malheureusement maintenant pour vous
obligé de vous désolidariser de cet
homme que vous avez absurdement admirer
pendant des années pour probablement des
réseaux d'argent et donc ce manque de
crédibilité je suis désolé je sais que
ça change avec l'espèce de ronronnement
qui est juste qu'il a jusque là votre
ami change avec avec l'air avec la
courtoisie surnommé nommé 6 mai qu'a eu
ce canal avec la comptable avait même
avec monsieur alex a été un peu dur mais
ça reste quand même un peu plus courte
et donc je pense que vous avez votre
ripolinage cette opération de com
invraisemblable que vous faites et qui
fonctionne plutôt je pense un là ce soir
vous feriez pas une seule question
maintenant vous faites une bonne
séquence mais je suis pas interviewer je
peux pour tous d'accord vous est offert
un réquisitoire bas madame on débat on
vous aide
il
continue voilà vous vous dites que ce
que ce que marina hands et laura
crédible voilà c'est ça que je dis je
pense que ces changements de pied sur
tous les sujets y compris les plus
importants d'année en année montre
qu'elle n'est pas crédible je pense
qu'elle met 15 ans à se rendre compte
qu'une idée qu'elle a proposé un jour
était en fait mauvaise donc le temps de
maturation d'une idée de marine le pen
ça me fait dire qu'il faut pas se
précipiter quand elle propose et donc je
pense que eric zemmour vous rend en
effet un service immense en vous
dédiabolisant parce qu'en effet il est
sans doute bien pire que vous sur les
questions sur les nazis qui a dans son
équipe et s'est même si vous vous disiez
beaucoup de bien d'alain soral n'y a pas
si longtemps et en plus si vous rend
mais oui madame les céréales il ya pas
si longtemps mais c'est une réalité vous
avez dit beaucoup de bien à la salle
dont on savait déjà très bien qui
c'était peu importe peu importe même sur
la peine de mort vous avez changé d'imad
dit des trois fois vous n'êtes pas
vraiment capable de dire mais peut-être
dire ce soir que vous êtes contre la
peine plus avoir de temps de parole
tellement vous avez parlé monsieur vous
avez un long temps de parole je ne sais
très bien donc pardon vous n'êtes pas si
différente que ça de lui mais vous rends
service puisque il vous dédiabolise et
d'une certaine manière ils vous
crédibilise un peu dans l'espèce
d'atonie général et moi ce que je
pensais que vous n'êtes pas crédible que
vous perdrez à nouveau cette élection
présidentielle et que donc vous rendez
service à emmanuel macron qui est en
train de voler l'élection présidentielle
aux français avec votre complice
monsieur consigne et moi je comprends
que vous soyez un peu amer je veux dire
parce que votre candidate qui était
donné au début d'ailleurs de cette
campagne très haut en capacité qu'on
disait on était la seule qui pouvait
battre aujourd'hui non seulement elle
n'est plus du tout en capacité ce cas
les quatrièmes ou cinquièmes de la
compétition il reste un mois et de soi
bien sûr il reste trois semaines tout
peut arriver mais quand même par
expérience je peux vous dire que il est
quand même assez rare si vous voulez
qu'on voit des courbes se croisent et
radicalement dans les derniers moments
mais bon ça peut imaginer que ça peut
arriver mais je comprends que vous soyez
un peu agacé mais surtout second tour on
voit que elle n'a pas la capacité de
gagner face à emmanuel macron est elle
la moins que moi donc je comprends cette
amère chavez mais on aurait pu évoquer
le sujet j'avais dit quelque chose vous
nous avez privé dont la possibilité de
débattre de tout à fait un réquisitoire
très désagréable faut le dire mais c'est
forcément mieux j'ai dit la vérité
marine le pen
vous avez j'avais dit tout à l'heure
c'est fait du mannequin avait dit à
leurs marines de fait ces consignes et
ça me fait par une manne pour vous
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que les
compteurs étaient remis à zéro au second
tour donc si là donc les les sondages du
second tour moi je les regarde pas trop
je regarde les sondages de prouver tout
un émoi comment ce que après c'est vrai
que après faut voir voilà donc c'est
vrai que c'est le candidat vous avez
raison donc voilà donc et valérie
pécresse pour avoir ses chances voilà au
second tour c'est le pas de ces luttes
au second tour on remet les compteurs à
zéro à peu près c'est vrai qu'après le
débat du dodo d'entre deux tours on sait
pas ce qu'il peut se passer oui mais
voilà il ya qu un problème si vous
voulez c'est que
valérie pécresse elle a peu ou prou
exactement le même programme qu emmanuel
macron résulte donc le problème c'est
que entre quelqu'un qui est en poste et
qui défend le programme de valérie
pécresse est quelqu'un qui n'est pas
évidemment le kansas à valérie pécresse
emmanuel macron va être considérablement
avantage est il présent ce programme
vous le verrez c'est exactement la même
chose c'est le style qui a fait de la
retraite à 65 ans mais vous 65 ans
d'ailleurs où 64 ans j'aimerais bien
qu'on en parle deux minutes parce que la
retraite à 64 ans ça va avoir une
conséquence faut que chacun comprenne
sauve elle c'est la baisse en fait des
pensions mais à la belle oui bien sûr ça
va sauver le système des retraites d'ici
mais d'autres moyens d'ailleurs il n'est
pas en danger le reste système des
retraites contrairement à ce qu'on lui
dit mais ça va surtout faire permettent
pour ceux qui vont la mettre en oeuvre
de faire baisser de 10% en fait
l'intégralité des pensions pourquoi
parce que déjà au moment où nous nous
parlons au moment où la retraite à 62
ans la moitié des gens qui arrivent à la
retraite n'ont pas de retraite pleine
c'est à dire qu'en réalité ils ont une
retraite des côtés imaginez vous que si
c'est déjà le cas à 62 ans à 64 ans
alors quasiment l'intégralité des
français n'auront pas de retraite pleine
l'objectif c'est rbc en fait de manière
générale l'intégralité des pensions de
10% et bien si c'est ça un projet
que je considère évidemment comme devant
être combattue donc moi mon projet est
clair il est juste il est de dire on
démarre tôt dans la vie plus on
travaille dur plus on part tôt et ça
veut dire que non s'avère longue juste
avant 17 ans existe une loi fillon
qu'ils attaquent 2003 avant 17 ans donc
moi ce que je souhaite c'est que
progressivement ceux qui
sont entrés dans le système avant 20 ans
puissent partir à 60 ans et 40 annuités
jusqu'à 62 ans et 42 annuités pour ceux
qui seraient rentrés les plus tard je
pense que son réseau nahar argent ça
coûte ne viole pas besoin de les former
ça coûte 9,5 milliards et formant c'est
clair tout le monde sait continue en
tête ils vont pouvoir sortir parce que
bien souvent les gens n'y comprennent
rien là tout le monde va comprendre
tellement c'est complexe là tout le
monde va comprendre à partir de quand on
peut partir à quel âge on peut partir et
les 9,6 milliards que ça coûte et bien
c'est un choix de rêve c'est un choix de
nos budgets pas de jeux vendus que je
fais et que j'assume mais je vous ai dit
madame je vais assumer la démagogie
c'est facile de dire c'est démago la
cimade réforme c'est ça qui est dingue
moi j'ai regardé votre programme il n'y
a pas de réforme de dans la salle
courage réformateur la france on sera
peut-être d'accord là dessus c'est un
trésor la france c'est un spécial
mais oui a besoin par exemple de ses
fonctionnaires dans certains domaines
louis dans certains domaines louis g
j'ai noté ici je sais plus je vois là
savez vous par exemple combien vous avez
d'agents sur l'alimentation la
consommation mais ont mis derrière n'a
en plus du ministère vous avez le
conseil national de l'alimentation
l'institut national de la consommation
l'observateur de l'alimentation
l'observatoire de la formation des prix
et des marges des produits alimentaires
le conseil national de la consommation
plus solitaire savons manière rien
changé mais ça ne vous fait pas ce que
vous voulez pas faire le rouge à temps
et parce que vers les agences est rien
comme ça évidemment il faut les
rationnaliser mais moins les gens j'ai
pas dit on en voyait des gens qui
travaillent là dedans moi j'irai les
mettre à la dgccrf pour lutter contre
les fraudes et pour lutter contre les
importations alimentaires frauduleuses
parce que je pense encore une fois qui a
beaucoup de fraudes dans notre pays et
que précisément tous ces gens dont vous
venez de parler pourrait parfaitement
faire des agents de surveillance
j'ai fait des faits frauduleux qui sont
autant de vols s'est gardé d'en dehors
bien merci
mais si les choix différent vous rira
bien vous mettez la poussière sous le
tapis que vous allez faire comme malraux
en scène signée dans une fiction vous
étiez lui vous faites comme à ce que
j'ai le droit et la positionner papa
mais riche en générant d'y avoir de
re-faire ses champions